I was born during a war
that still engulfs
my country, Afghanistan.
When I was growing up,
violence was all around me.
I remember sitting
in my living room with my family
when a distant thud
would jerk us all out of our seats.
As the sound of the rockets
came closer and closer,
our bodies would coil and freeze.
My grandmother would take charge
of her terrified flock
and shepherd us into a room
in the back of the house.
No less exposed, but to us,
it somehow felt safer.
I'd cling to my granny and clench my fists
wondering why this was happening to us.
I clearly remember
my little brother's face wincing
every time we heard a rocket fall.
It was this violence,
this war that still goes on today,
which forced my family to leave our home.
We left early one morning
not knowing where we would end up.
Along the way, there was more violence.
We drove on roads with landmines,
and everywhere we went,
there was hostility.
The overriding memory
in my body of those years
is of feeling unsafe.
Feeling as though something terrible
would happen to me
or to my family.
We worried about our friends
and family back home.
My grandmother was still in Kabul,
and I missed her terribly.
I'd go to bed at night
and say the prayers she taught me
to pray for her safety.
We wanted nothing more
than to go back home.
But when the Taliban took over
the country in 1996,
my parents realized
that was no longer an option.
So after four years of living in exile,
we sought asylum in the UK
and began a new life.
I started going to school.
And almost 25 years later,
I'm standing here with you.
I'm now working to help others
overcome devastation by war.
To overcome the trauma
of being expendable.
In my work,
I see how living under constant
threat of violence and feeling unsafe
can affect people,
even when they manage to get out.
War leaves a physical legacy in our body,
our mind and in our spirit.
When I tell people about my life,
they sometimes say
it's a remarkable story.
But this is not true.
Millions of people are living
through war and displacement,
trying to survive.
For these people, like my family,
the dream isn't to get rich
or to go on vacations
or to buy that perfect house.
They have a modest,
yet somehow still extravagant
dream of being safe.
They dream of a day
when they can go to the market
without the fear of violence.
Or send their kids to school
without being afraid for their lives.
War is dislocating.
It gets inside your body
and makes you into a thing,
a corpse.
It can dislodge empathy, hope and joy
and replace them with fear.
The fear that comes from living
in the violence of war
can break social bonds,
disbanding the very communities
we rely on for safety.
Women and children I work with
complain about pain in their body.
Children as young as three or four
talk about hurt in their bellies
and not because they're hungry.
It's a pain I know well.
A constant, dull ache all over your body,
and it feels as though nothing
can alleviate it.
People have nightmares
and experience overwhelming emotions:
grief, sadness and anger.
"Why did I deserve this," they wonder.
This is the situation facing 84 million
forcibly displaced people.
And according to UNHCR,
more than half are women and children.
What's even more startling
is the number of people
living in active conflict zones.
According to Save the Children,
420 million children are growing up
in places where violence is the norm.
These are families and children
subject to forces they cannot control.
Yet war and violence don't become normal.
The stress and trauma experienced
by people who go through war
is itself deadly.
Illnesses like cancer,
diabetes and heart disease
have been linked to trauma
and chronic stress.
But it's the psychic pain
that affects people the most.
Depression, PTSD
and other psychiatric disorders
affect a significant percentage
of people who go through war.
I was shocked when I learned
that since 9/11,
four times more US soldiers
have taken their own lives
than died in combat.
Reconciling to normal life
after you've seen life-shattering war
can be the hardest of tasks
for a human being.
But mental health and healing
are often overlooked
when supporting people
who have survived war.
And that's why I set up
Refugee Trauma Initiative,
to help support the mental health
of those affected by war and displacement.
Our organization is one of several
around the world that helps people
so they can begin to feel safe again.
When feeling safe is splintered
and you feel unsafe and unseen,
we work to help bring
the internal safe system back online.
We create spaces where people can convene
and heal as a community.
In our groups, men, women and children
reconnect with their bodies,
have the space to express
what they are feeling,
and most importantly,
reconnect with others.
We use art, mindfulness,
dance and storytelling
to help make sense of the dislocating
experiences of violence
and of being forced to leave your home.
And everything that we do
is underpinned by value-based practice.
We practice understanding, curiosity
and respect to everyone
who comes through the door.
We recognize and acknowledge their trauma
without pathologizing or medicalizing
their very normal human reaction
to the reckless violence
they've experienced.
And we recognize that these experiences
are the result of systemic injustice
and oppression that often
have colonial roots,
which has dehumanized
and killed people for centuries.
At the heart of our work is a simple
yet fundamental notion
that feelings of safety
are inextricably tied to feeling
connected to a community.
A community where you feel
worthy and seen.
Where your suffering
will be recognized and cared for,
where you can experience belonging.
Understanding how violence and conflict
affects and changes people
is more important than ever.
Our world is embroiled
in multiple chronic conflicts
that seem to have no end in sight.
Since 1945, there have been 150
conflicts around the world,
and the overwhelming majority
of casualties have been civilians.
We can't talk about this human toll of war
without talking about the war industry.
The war on terror over the last 20 years
unleashed a new kind of violence,
displacing 38 million people.
This is a war that made
drone warfare the norm.
Drones enable automated extermination.
As we are moving closer and closer
towards automation of war,
what happens when we outsource violence,
the extinguishing of a human life,
to a computer?
What happens to us
as an interconnected global community
when a machine and not a human
decides whether a life is worth something?
This is all bleak,
but not hopeless.
There's always room to adjust
our trajectory to a better future.
I'm standing here in the most powerful
country in the world,
a citizen of the United Kingdom,
two countries that have long
held power over war and peace.
And the first thing that we can do
is demand that our governments
stop investing in mass destruction.
At a time when we need to invest
in tackling climate change
and in health care,
our governments are financing
weapons and drones.
Every vote that we cast should be
against weapons of mass destruction,
against automation of war.
(Applause)
And you can do something
in your own community.
Right now, there are literally
millions of Afghans
who are brutally forced
to leave their home.
Like them, there are Syrians,
Iraqis, Burundians
who all have to deal with the fallout
of war and displacement.
And the antidote to their suffering
lies in the kindness and connection
of the communities
where they find themselves.
If they can feel safe there,
they can begin to heal
and start a new life.
It's sometimes hard for us to see
that the answers to some of the most
complicated problems in the world
lie in the simplest of human actions.
It may sound too easy
that a good neighbor can help
to heal the wounds of war.
But in my experience, this is true.
Before we landed in London,
after months of hardship,
we stopped in a poor neighborhood
of a town in Central Asia.
I was forlorn, grief stricken
and not yet able to imagine
a future without violence.
One day, a neighborhood teacher
knocked on our door.
When we opened the door,
we saw a kindly middle-aged woman
carrying a box of pens, colored pencils,
paper and children's books.
She asked my parents if she could come in
and spend time with us.
They let her in, and from that day,
she visited us most days after school.
When I told her that I desperately
wanted to go to school,
she took me to her classroom,
where the girls had prepared gifts.
They taught me how to sing a song.
It wasn't long before we had to move on,
and once we left, I never saw her again.
But what she did
made me feel valued and safe.
The memory of that experience
had left a blueprint
of what it felt to inhabit my body,
if only for a moment, without fear.
A memory of joy and belonging.
And to this day, when I feel the opposite,
I can close my eyes
and feel that connection.
And it carries me through the dark days.
Thank you.
(Applause)